>> Tucker: WELL, CHURCHES WERE
CLOSED ACROSS AMERICA BUT
PLANNED PARENTHOOD CLINIC STAYED
OPEN THANKS TO THE POLITICIANS
THEY PAID OFF.
ABORTIONS WERE INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND MADE THAT POINT EXPLICITLY.
DESPITE THAT ADVANTAGE, THEY
ENJOYED OVER LEGITIMATE
BUSINESSES, DESPITE THE FACT
THAT THE NATIONAL ORGANIZATION
PLANNED PARENTHOOD, THOUSANDS OF
EMPLOYEES, PLANNED PARENTHOOD
AFFILIATES STILL COLLECTED
$80 MILLION FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT, MONEY THAT WAS MEANT
TO ASSIST SMALL BUSINESSES.
YOU FIRST HEARD ABOUT THAT WHEN
THEY SHOWED TWO NIGHTS AGO.
NOW 27 REPUBLICAN SENATORS HAVE
ASKED THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
TO INVESTIGATE WHERE THAT MONEY
WAS SENT TO PLANNED PARENTHOOD
IN THE FIRST PLACE.
MEANWHILE, AN INTERVIEW LAST
WEEK, THEY CELEBRATED THE SILVER
LINING OF THE CORONAVIRUS.
SO ARE THE YOUNG THANKS TO
TELEMEDICINE.
>> MEDICATION ABORTION IS
OFFERED EARLIER IN THE
GESTATIONAL PERIOD AND IT REALLY
REQUIRES JUST TWO PILLS WITH A
24-HOUR PERIOD.
IN MANY CASES, WERE ABLE TO SEE
A PATIENT WITH THE EXPANSION OF
TELEHEALTH, AND TAKE THE
PATIENT’S AND THEN THAT PATIENT
WILL PICK UP THE PRESCRIPTION
AND COME HOME AND TAKE THAT
MEDICATION SAFELY AT HOME.
AND ACTUALLY A SILVER LINING IN
THIS PANDEMIC.
>> Tucker: SILVER LINING.
JUST WHEN I YOU THOUGHT A
PROFESSIONAL COULDN’T GET MORE
COULIS OR ANTIHUMAN, THEY DO.
AN EDITOR AT TOWN HALL, HAPPY TO
HAVE HER ON TONIGHT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING ON.
HOW DO YOU THINK PLANNED
PARENTHOOD, WHICH AGAIN TAKES
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
SCHOLARSHIPS FROM TAXPAYERS
EVERY YEAR.
THE LARGEST GET OUT, AND HOW ARE
THEY POSING AS A SMALL BUSINESS
AND GETTING AWAY WITH IT?
>> TUCKER, NOT ONLY DO THEY GET
500 MILLION PLUS DOLLARS FROM
TAXPAYERS EVERY YEAR BUT THEY
HAVE 600 MILLION PLUS DOLLARS
THAT COME INTO THE PRIVATE
DONATIONS EVERY YEAR, $2 BILLION
IN ASSETS AND $2 BILLION IN
REVENUE WITH HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS LEFT OVER
FOR THINGS LIKE THIS.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE DETAILS OF
THE AFFILIATES, DOZENS OF THEM
HAVE APPLIED FOR THIS, SMALL
BUSINESS FUNDING, THE MAIN
UMBRELLA ORGANIZATION PLANNED
PARENTHOOD IS SAYING, WELL, WE
DID NOT PLAY AS A BIG
ORGANIZATION BUT THE SMALL
ORGANIZATIONS AFFILIATED WITH
THE SUPPLY BECAUSE THEY SHOULD
BE ELIGIBLE GIVEN THE SMALL
NUMBER OF EMPLOYEES.
SO THAT IS THE WAY THEY ARE
SUPPLYING IT.
THE VICE PRESIDENT OF GOVERNMENT
WELFARE SAYING THE FDA WHICH IS
ASKING THE AFFILIATES TO GIVE
THE MONEY BACK, THAT THE
BUSINESS’ UNRELENTING ATTACKS ON
ABORTION RIGHTS.
BUT THEY ALSO ARGUE THAT THESE
AFFILIATES THAT THE MONEY WAS
BEING USED TO SAVE EMPLOYEE
PAYCHECKS.
WELL, IF IT WAS ABOUT SAVING
EMPLOYEE PAYCHECKS, WHY IS SHE
MAKING THE ARGUMENT THAT THIS IS
AN ATTACK ON ABORTION RIGHTS?
>> Tucker: THAT IS A VERY GOOD
POINT, BUT WHAT YOU WERE SAYING,
IT WOULD BE LIKE IF THE APPLE
STORE IN GEORGETOWN OR MIDTOWN
MANHATTAN APPLIED FOR A SMALL
BUSINESS LOAN ON THE GROUNDS,
THEY ARE A SMALL BUSINESS
BECAUSE AND WE HAVE 80
EMPLOYEES?
>> RIGHT.
RIGHT.
BUT THEN THE APPLE HEADQUARTERS
IN CALIFORNIA DID NOT APPLY
BECAUSE THEY HAVE THOUSANDS OF
EMPLOYEES AND LOTS OF RESOURCES.
BUT THE PLANNED PARENTHOOD
ACTION FUND CAME OUT WITH A
STATEMENT EARLY ON WHEN THE
CARES ACT FIRST PAST AND PLANNED
PARENTHOOD IS NOT ELIGIBLE FOR
THIS.
SO THE QUESTION THAT THE
SENATORS HAVE FOR THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT TO LOOK INTO IS
WHETHER OR NOT THESE
APPLICATIONS WERE MADE IN A
VALID, NONFRAUDULENT WAY.
WHY IS IT SOME AFFILIATES UNDER
PLANNED PARENTHOOD SHOULD BE
RECEIVING PLENTY OF MONEY FROM
THIS MASSIVE ORGANIZATION WERE
GETTING TAXPAYER MONEY AND WILL
THEY BE FORCED TO GIVE IT BACK
GIVEN THE VAST MAJORITY OF
RESOURCES THAT THEY HAVE?
>> Tucker: THAT IS EXACTLY